[Aplausos]
jerusalén conmemora el domingo de ramos
con una procesión a la que pese a la
pandemia acudieron decenas de fieles
para recrear la entrada de jesús desde
el monte de los olivos
y comenzamos la semana santa este año
gracias a dios podemos celebrar
hay mucha gente no tanta como lo normal
pero es mucho mejor espero que sea el
inicio de un nuevo comienzo no solo para
jerusalén sino para todo el mundo
es normal para el papá francisco dirigió
la jornada en la que participaron sólo
120 creyentes y 30 cardenales en la
basílica de san pedro que por segundo
año consecutivo lució prácticamente
vacía
un esfuerzo el año pasado nos
sorprendimos este año estamos más
presionados y la crisis económica se ha
agravado
en esta situación histórica y social y
les toma la cruz y se hace cargo del mal
que esta realidad conlleva un mal físico
psicológico y sobre todo espiritual
histórica eso chávez
en el líbano los sacerdotes optaron por
recorrer las calles a bordo de
camionetas desde las que lanzaron agua
bendita a los pobladores
[Música]
estamos pasando el domingo de ramos en
casa respetando las órdenes del gobierno
de distanciamiento social y uso de
mascarillas estamos obligados a hacer lo
que podemos hacer en fruta de la belle
en contraste cerca de 25.000 fieles
salieron a las calles iraquíes para
hacer parte de los actos religiosos
es un domingo de ramos especial soy de
kirkuk la celebración es más que
maravillosa y el ambiente es realmente
bueno
en países latinoamericanos como honduras
solo se permitió el acceso a las
iglesias a pocos creyentes con
distanciamiento social
mientras que en paraguay la bendición de
las palmas fue recibida por los fieles
desde sus automóviles y en perú chile y
venezuela la llamada semana mayor inició
bajo estricta a 49